yeah if that tick tock didn't make it
clear camila cabello is officially
taking kelly clarkson's seat on the
voice at least for season 22.
i mean i'm so excited camila made the
reveal on sunday following in the
digital footsteps of returning coach
gwen stefani who posted her own duet
with husband blake shelton and returning
coach john legend a couple days earlier
i love being here this is gwen's first
time back on the voice since season 19
and camila's first time ever taking that
iconic red seat though like kelly she
has some practice when it comes to
singing competitions getting her start
on the x factor
[Music]
now we don't know why kelly is taking a
break from the voice though it might
have something to do with her talk show
sliding into ellen degeneres's coveted
time slot this fall i mean it's a dream
i didn't know i had and i mean it turned
out to be like such a dream job like i
love it but this likely doesn't mean the
end of kelly's time as a voice coach
it's pretty common for the stars to come
and go as long as the formula stays the
same
what works
is super super famous people like
high-end
a-list people right like lifestyles of
the rich and famous these guys can buy
and sell us all day long but they're
great people
that juxtaposition is what makes a great
voice coach
they really have the world is their
oyster they're at the top of their game
but they're great people they look in
the eye they remember where they come
from they have great traditional values
and all of that plays into great
television for us
[Music]
you